an international conference trying to
raise money for millions of syrians
facing extreme poverty has failed to
meet its target
the virtual talks raised five and a half
billion euros that's three billion euros
short of the goal
now the u.n officials say that the
situation in syria is dire and getting
worse
because of coronavirus
stranded in lebanon the u.n is ensuring
the survival of this syrian family
with the equivalent of 23 euros per
person per month
the problem is the ongoing economic
crisis means that's no longer enough
sugar and oil have become expensive
to continue help aid organizations need
to generate more
money this is one of our biggest
struggle is to remind
the international community reminds
donor remind
actors that the crisis is still creating
difficulties
the fifth donors conference hosted by
the eu and the un
was trying to raise enough money to
provide another year of aid
for 13 million syrian refugees
they need our full support and of course
proper funding is crucial
today germany is therefore making its
largest pledge
in the last four years 1.738 billion
euros
the donors want to offer money for
emergency aid not reconstruction
to avoid supporting the assad regime the
regime offers
no future to the syrian people
it makes no contribution to the
stability
on the region unless these changes
it cannot be a partner to the european
union
the summit failed to reach its goal
meaning there'll be fewer resources for
people in need
and for more we are joined now by
catherine langensieben who is a
spokesperson for syria for germany's
green party and a member of the european
parliament welcome to the program and
thank you so much for joining us
um we've just been hearing about these
initiatives
um this is the the fifth time this
conference is taking place still the
money
that's needed hasn't been raised in full
what's your reaction
yeah it's uh it's a pity that it's so
hard
to collect the money and of course it's
a shame for the world that there's no
peace in syria there be no peace and
that's
what we need um
otherwise we are spending money again
and again
for the next upcoming 10 years 15
million years
and that's can't be the solution i'm
proud to announce okay so to address um
that fundamental security situation
um is quite important but you know in in
the meantime
um there there is this money that is
needed and i'd like to talk with you
about that in the context of the
pandemic
and whether or not you might think that
donors might be using the pandemic as an
excuse for their continued failure to
help get
syria the help it needs
yeah there are countries who are
struggling with covet and
and are more interested probably uh
in in in their own interests or to solve
the problems within their own countries
but
we have to help the people and the
people in syria
need the international help so yeah
for the moment we need the money for
emergency
help for food for water for
health care for the woman for the
children
i urge the international
community to help its urgents
but we have to find an international
solution for the syrian people for the
next years
to have a real future for the next
generation
and we know that germany was a key donor
you mentioned some of those uh
key areas where where you would like the
money to be used
where do you see as the most urgent
right now
the urgent is to bring food to the
people the people
need something to eat they need
to pay for the daily
yeah things they have to they need it
for
for their children for their daily life
i need soap
i need water i need food
so if i don't survive the next
upcoming days or my children die on
hunger
i'm not thinking about the next upcoming
election or who will be my next
president
so food is that what people need we need
the money for food and to stabilize
the situation the daily situation for
the people and most of them are women
elder people babies catherine logan deep
sieben serious spokesperson for
germany's green party thank you so much
thank you